all right we all know that Brent is
swinging that he went to LA and he had
sex and his wife had sex on her own so
we're planning Hollywood Squares for
Christmas somebody has a great idea
Brent's wife Caitlyn would be the center
square except she would be a couple with
the jackhammer I go that's a brilliant
idea
and what happened Brent blew a [ __ ] fit
really you went to California right
Kaitlyn [ __ ] the jackhammer in your
head correct and having him on Hollywood
Squares with her is crossing the line
way over the line why don't you think
what love jackhammer [ __ ] Caitlyn in
your bed is over the line no you guys
are again are not understanding what
I've said on the air we have a very
close relationship we're not I know and
to be fair just so the audience how fun
would it be to meet the jackhammer and
hear those two in the center square it
would be terrible
why for you my for my wife my wife
doesn't want to get there and have you
paint her as she doesn't love her
husband I but what I would never paint
her that way like if she's sitting there
with a guy that she [ __ ] like it's her
boy Ryan that's how it's not like her
boy this is the guy who [ __ ] Kaitlyn
right but what would that's not her
boyfriend I get it she likes to [ __ ] and
move on I mean this is my thing like the
guy was in your home he's looking at
pictures of you guys my fridge he's
banging your wife in your bed and you
don't think lines have been crossed
already agreed to that but I was not
asking them to [ __ ] on the air it's it's
literally a game show it's it's a bit
like I'm looking for funny squares and
what a funny square Kaitlyn and the jack
I get what the humor is but it make fun
of you with all of my expense yes you're
jealous
I'm fine I was finally jealous when it
comes to sex I got no problem with it
when it comes to being weird was it in
the writing room when you guys brought
this it was like this but in a writers
room full of people it was odd it was
very uncomfortable because our job is to
make jokes yeah what I think it is when
you agree okay you're gonna go [ __ ]
other people you don't assume the other
person is going to be a porn star called
the jackhammer that's what it is yeah
that's what this is
what if he was sitting in another square
I mean that's fine if the separate
squares right to find the square in half
between oh my god you know Howard the
thought behind it was that this is you
we could use Hollywood Squares is almost
a look back at the year and write the
biggest stories I call that with Caitlyn
and that's what I am so what I never
thought bright would say that's
unacceptable that didn't even occur to
me and was disrespected
I would say I don't mind my wife being
in a square with a guy right on a TV
show right I just don't want her [ __ ]
him and blow him he's saying yeah but
don't let them sit next to their old
prince dark world that's how it works
and we were all shocked like you we
weren't in the meeting - [ __ ] Brent /
Ryan I was more shocked I talked to him
after the meeting trying to come up with
funny ideas I just go I don't know how
you thought that we were all supposed to
know that this was the red line yeah who
would know that I've explained on the
air our marriage we wouldn't know that
Depar sitting in a square next to a guy
is way worse to you than our [ __ ] a
guy right that's a line you really
that's really afraid I mean as I try and
explain to me one of Einstein's theorems
you know what I mean like I'm like I'm
never gonna follow that line I
understand you my wife could sit next to
a guy in a square all [ __ ] day be my
guest that's fine with me
don't [ __ ] you're looking at it
through your prisoner I guess your
friend you should be in prison